I think, for me, the definition of success...
...is closing the distance between dream to reality.
Since I started using machine intelligence in my work,...
...I can truly feel that...
...when I say I would like to take my brush...
...and dip it into the machine's mind...
...and paint with machine consciousness that act itself...
...has a deep emotional connection with an entity, with a system.
Hello, I'm Refik Anadol.
I'm a media artist and director.
My work is completely human-centric.
My work is all about human emotions...
...and feeling connected with the environment that we inhabit.
And I do hope that every single mind and soul can feel it,...
...can play with it and enjoy being human in the 21st century.